tutti ragazzi minuti questo video sono
fa vj oggi siamo tornati su cui ogni
volta mica sono troppo mondo di questo
non so perché ok ci siamo riuniti con
house è la cosa più bella del mondo tu
sei veramente un figo zio e la prosa in
belize avrei cos'è amsu prender l'acqua
che ti ok a posto già vinto perfetto da
due sono le mie fottute medaglie anche
ragazzi a fare sta roba adesso che è che
sono con hansel dove riuscire a superare
il dovrei riuscire a superare il lago
perché siamo in due almeno quello
dovremo andare mi seguivano mi stai
facendo andare se sei un deficiente non
mi caga manco a morire ecco sarebbe
un'idea quella tipo c'è stata anche se
fa bene
madonna ma c'è un collo d'acciaio zio
non voglio sapere dov'è finito ma hansel
se il veicolo a motore tsi bello della
storia perché uno che voglia fare un
giro su hansen sono 5 euro a giro chiusa
estero ma è un puzzle si pazzo o
cliccato due cose a casa bene così ce ne
è che se questa è una padella
ho trovato una padella grazie brava così
ragazzo trovato nella roba a terra che
non so che cosa comunque che ho trovato
un occhio che non lo sapessi tuffati
giusto mi sembra la cosa più bella in un
mare così limpido esatto zia sconfitti
ma come fai ad essere la ac da quest
acqua cristallina
io veramente cos'è questa cosa
seriamente
ah beh mi chiedi tu cosa mi serve c'è
una caraffa che grossa quanto il mio
mignolo che ma sei serio da adesso in
avanti però tutti dovete provare ad
andare in giardino a buttare un
bicchiere d'acqua sugli alberi vedere se
crescono perché non ci crederò mai nella
vita
si no sì sì già fatto che qui ebbe ma
bastava dirlo prima e vai che faccio
cadere tutto va bene era otro trovato
una mela sono contento basta ho vinto
come ha fatto farlo scappare l'ultima
volta che adesso c'è ansia che può
bloccarlo blocca la adesso adesso è ma
sei un rincoglionito nell'anima
va bè ragazzi son belli qua nova vena
figata sta roba
io voglio farmi il bagno nelle foto del
ponte ecco infatti cento al mulino che
non ho capito nel mulino che vorrei c'è
soltanto favi geni sicuro non c'è ansie
testa di ca vabbè mi fai sai girare una
mano verni sorprendi zio vabbè raga io
io io ho raggiunto il massimo del
godimento in questo gioco cosa stai
facendo
ag rete come cazzo ti chiami arance sto
andando a [ __ ] nelle pozzanghere beh
io amo questo giorno e sta andando a
cazzo si è sbagliato un gioco ragazzi
adoro tutto questo vi va di fare un
bagno con me nella terra anche se nella
terra non ci si può tuffare ma io posso
io continuo a sguazzare nel terreno non
so come tu continua a far girare il
mulino zio che io devo capire cos'è sta
roba
una torcia non ci dall ad una base voi
c'è una pala
un'altra palla a questa è una michetta
una pala pensate che genio continua a
far girare il mulino zio casa tutti più
contenti ma mi stai prendendo per il
culo un regalo non ce la posso più fare
il mio fratello lo devo uccidere ci
pensa da solo
ascoltami no no no no scalzava scherza
allora tv il filo st fiamma nel deretano
sa vuoi impe cosa dovrebbe essere quella
roba lì c'è adesso che l'ho presa mi
devi spiegare il senso di no io non non
passata rigirano innaffia alle cose cioè
non solo giardiniere porca [ __ ]
c'è prima è cresciuto un cazzo di albero
adesso è diventato verde un ramoscello
ma che posso prenderlo
cioè sta roba comunque a questo vuole un
occhio ma ma ovvio adesso te lo ritrova
se vieni qua che tosta comunque ragazzi
a parte stack agata vediamo di andare ma
che è sta roba che non ho capito ancora
ma [ __ ] cioè una roba si sa ah sì si
cerca madonna 86 brutto vinto anche una
freccia con come osi toccarmi ti
denuncio per pedofilia da o seriamente
ma perché li mortacci allora io no no no
merda scalda mia
la freccia tele infilo comunque nel culo
e ho trovato una cosa che non ho idea di
dove sia finita ma va a è questa cos'è
lo vedo in via questo sono le lucciole
c'è una trovata la cosa le monete si
figo c'è una strana ma fermi un attimo
ma come facciate negli occhiali andare
avanti non posso andare avanti ci va lo
stesso che il maestro muten no a zio tu
6 il mio idolo sappino c'è ti amo
trovato diverso dalle 18 monete tra c'è
un cappello i picchi se ti vengo a
salutare tipo no ma si ciancia la storia
anche voglio capire se allora è andato
lì davanti ha parlato agli anni ha
rubato la faccia anche a luglio ho
capito eh vabbè poi si è rimasto senza
faccia a salve adesso che so la sua
storia posso venire a prendere il
cappello mi fa passare o mischiate ci
avrei scommesso la mamma se senti fra te
e io passo uguale su che è un cappello
che cazzo di domande ti fai
sì sì già fatta ho trovato è stordito di
brutto e il cattivo specchio e velista
specchiare sotto lo infilo superiori ho
preso la faccia perfetto perché ho
trovato anche un cappello a posto vinto
tutta scalda maestro ho trovato la sua
faccia il suo cappello sono 50 euro
avrebbe voglia di prendersela facciano
perché bruttissimo così a che beh vabbè
dai un paio di lifting siamo a poco e ti
portano a quattro formaggi e una coca
giusto al posto giusto così ok puoi
suonare molto cazzo ti pare ma la mancia
la voglia uguale
il senso di questa cosa che ho appena
fatto qual è di precisi ma che cazzo fai
là dentro ansie volevo andare qua
comunque prima di tutto è una roba sei
un altro enigma al celo celo celo ciò si
sa posto è solo un gene roba si
previsioni del meteo by fa vj ragazze è
una roba del giorno ascolti sia anche a
lei li foto la faccio io io vado in giro
a [ __ ] faccia alla gente
grazie a questa non era faccia della
tizia di prima quella dello scorso
episodio ma regala la vado a prendere
perché questa è questa qui per forza sì
io voglio veramente sam presidente degli
stati uniti dopo questa cosa
no è molto ma dopo che l'avevano uccisa
quindi no vabbè dai non può uscire così
però è da meno se mi faccio i cazzi miei
allora cosa tipo 2 miliardi di monete
quindi posso comprarmi kazakistan giuste
giuste cazzo mediando devo fare un mutuo
per prendere delle cose da sto tizio io
ho comprato tutto io vorrei capire il
senso si è capito e beh allora fallo
kull no vabbè ma non puoi farlo così a
sangue freddo ragazzi 10 secondi ho
ammazzato 22 essere umano va bene essere
umano proprio mac
comunque a parte sta roba si sblocca è
infatti trovato un occhio anche quello
che devo dare al corso come che si
chiama la statua dai vai vera eccoci qua
c'è anche un ponte tra l'altro finto che
io non ho capito il senso comunque aki
credo dall'occhio questo qui per te ma
vai con l'occhio forza
vai tieni d'occhio fai quello che vuoi
lo sapevo che c'era il pole man ci avrei
scommesso ha però non si è sbloccato ma
perché devo dire anche il suo desiderio
lo so why anche tu una pizza ai quattro
formaggi io c'ho un arco lo vuoi no voi
questo acquisto
sì sì ce l'ho a posto ho vinto non lo
vito ho vinto uno a vito cosa vuoi
ancora che cazzo lalalala si cela
l'ampia nacho su tutto
[Musica]
c'è
ma la madonna vabbè ma quando la classe
non è non era pa comunque ragazzino non
sono troppo forte non cedendo sbloccato
il ponte sono la persona più
intelligente del mondo giorno sono resto
tiziano mi vuole tanto bene non so
perché è giusto perciò un arco con una
freccia che no no no no corri corri
corri corri corri corri veloce veloce
verneau no no no no no no no no no no no
non ha preso che culo segrete le ansie
non è un cappuccetto rosso cazzo dove
dovevo andare questo lupo
ma porca [ __ ] ma non aspetta magari non
mi fa niente forse no eva è la madonna
baby doll chi è vedevano di tanto non li
chiamo il pedigree ceo e spunta una mano
tra l'altro a posso usarlo larga da
lillo subito cazzo slayer e la madonna
con fenomeni comunque ragazzi ha ucciso
un lupo a caso trova bene e tanto ansia
si è suicidato secondo me sotto il ponte
prova bene cos'è che devo fare dove
stiamo andando io non sto più capendo
cos'è fino alla parte iii cosa vuol dire
che questa roma
c'è una ragazza è una cosa enorme
confronti e finisce così ma veramente
finito no dai mica siamo arrivati alla
parte bella cioè mezz'ora per arrivare
qui finisce così ragazzi è stato
stupendo ma c'è e hansel e gretel 3
credo che l'abbiano già fatto non ne
sono sicuro ragazzi madonna molte volte
sono morti farò di sicuro 3 quando
uscirà perché un gioco così senza senso
non l'ho mai visto però va bene quindi
ragazzi concludo qui episodi a cosa è
servito è piaciuta sotto commento mi
piace anche a face di facebook e come la
nido tratta la descrizione cioè se
volessi discreta cv devono prossimo
bello ragazzi